uh let me ask the big ridiculous
question what do you think is the
meaning of life
or maybe the easier version of that is
what brings your life joy
so i'll just answer that one personally
for me um i'm a little bit weird i sort
of
i guess you can tell that but i see the
pen and pencil discussion from earlier
yes yeah yeah
so i mean my thing is i guess i
personally
just wanted to maximize a certain score
which was for how many person years
after i'm no longer
here anymore did what i do mattered
yeah and it didn't matter if it's
necessarily attributed to me it's just
like
did it did it matter and so that's what
i that's what i
wanted um i guess that is very inspired
by
how scientists work it's like why do we
keep talking about newton it's because
newton discovered some interesting
things and so newton's score is pretty
high
it's going to be infinity right well
let's hope it's infinity but pretty high
ah yes yes so you're going for so person
person years you're going for like
triple digits you're going for
it's like newton is like four digits
probably like a thousand years
yeah yeah or personal lifetimes like how
do you like to think well what are we
sorry i've met people times years people
times so so then it's like
actually this is huge this his like
going to be billions or trillions yeah
right the trillions but um i guess
for me i actually changed the metric
after a while and the reason is because
you may have seen i found some simple
way to solve quadratic equations
that is easier than every textbook yes
so
my score might already be not bad which
is why i decided then let's change it
into
the number of hours in the lifetimes as
well so the way i was doing it
before is that
if a person was sort of remembering
or using or or or appreciating what i
had done
for for like 10 years if
of their life oh that would count as 10
i see so if there was one person who for
10 years
yes remembered or appreciated something
i did that counts as a score of 10 and
we add up over all people
yes and then uh and that was with the
hypothesis that the score
would be very finite in the sense that
if i didn't come up with anything that
might potentially help a lot of
generations
in a forever way then your score will be
finite because at some point
it's not people don't remember that you
made like nice bottles or something
right but then after the quadratic
equation thing
it was that there's some chance that
that actually might make it into
textbooks
yes and if it makes it in textbooks the
chance that there will be an easier way
discovered is actually quite small
yes so in that case then the score might
get bigger
i was just saying the score might
actually already have been achieved in
non-trivial way so see because it's fun
to think about
because it could be different you can
achieve a high score
by a small number of people using it for
most of their lifetime and then
generations and generations
or you can have if we do dissipate if we
do spread colonize
become multi-planetary species you could
have that little
um a clever way to solve differential
equations
um uh spread
through like trillions of people as they
yes spread throughout the galaxy
and they it would they would only use it
each one
a few hours in their lifetime but yes
their kids will use it the kids the kids
will use it it'll spread and you'll have
that
impact in that kind of way yes so that's
why i renormalized it because i was like
well that's kind of dumb because what's
the importance of that that will save
people 15 minutes
um but so so what i meant is i didn't
want to count that as the main score
well i'm gonna have to try to come up
with uh some kind of device that
everyone would want to use maybe to make
coffee because
coffee seems to be the prevalent uh
performance enhancing chemical that
everyone uses so
i'll have to think about in those kinds
of metrics yeah but
but you see that that's just giving an
idea of i guess what i found meaningful
in general like whether or not it's like
whether or not that quadratic thing is
important or not
the general idea was i wanted to do
things that would outlast me
yes and that was what inspired me and
that's just how i choose what problems
to work on
and that's the kind of immortalities
ideas that you've
invented living on long after you
in the minds of others and humans are
ultimately not
are like meat vehicles
that carry ideas for brief for just a
few years
may not be the important thing it might
be the ideas that we carry with us
and invent new ones like we get a bunch
of baby ideas in our head
we borrow them from others and then
maybe we invent a new one
and that new one might have a life of
its own and
it's fun it's fun to think about that
idea living from many centuries to come
unless we destroy ourselves but maybe ai
will borrow it
and we'll remember poe as like that one
human that
that that helped us out um before we of
course killed him and the rest
of human civilization on that note
well this is a huge honor you're one of
the great educators
i've uh ever gotten a chance to interact
with so it's it's truly an honor that
you were talking with me today
it means especially a lot that you would
travel out to austin to talk to me
it really means a lot so thank you so
much keep on inspiring
and i'm one of your many many students
thank you so much for talking today
thank you thank you it's actually a real
honor for me to talk to you and to get
this chance to have this
really intellectual conversation through
all of these topics thanks
you